it goes a lot deeper than simply rich
people in government who don't give a
[__]
there is a problem of our Economic
Institutions are intellectually bankrupt
and I I that sounds extreme but listen
I've got a degree from LSC I've got a
degree from Oxford I've worked I've been
in think tanks I've been in the city
I've been in economics for
18 years now in many different spaces
my honest opinion is that economics is
intellectually bankrupt as a discipline
that most of what they do is a complete
waste of time most of these guys it
would be better off if we just sent them
out of the country and started again
because they are absolutely tied to a
set of models that have no distribution
in them keep predicting things will get
better things keep getting worse and
they will never figure it out they will
never figure it out because it is in
their blood to not consider the
distribution
add to that they're getting [__] paid
for it they're not the guys getting hurt